CK
INTO THAT MINNESOTA ZONE.
HERE COMES FOLIGNO AGAIN.
DROPS IT BACK.K. BOARDS.
GREENWAY THEREFORE THE WILD.
GOT IT TO THE
THIS IS THE SPACE IN THE
NEUTRALS ON WE TALKED ABOUT. ON
THE SCORESHEET AFTER WE SAW THA
.
FIALA DUMPS IT I I PLAY.
>> ED IMPRESSIVE DISPLAY OF
PATIENTS.ASSIST, HIS FIFTH OF T
SEASON.
SENDS IT BACK INTO HIS OWN ZONE
BETTER SHOT, BUT HE LOOKS FOR
HIS BUDDY, KAPRIZOV.
HERE IS THE LOOK I WAS TALAL
IT ALMOST LOOKED LIKE HARTMAN
WAS SHAKING HIS HEAD SAYING I
OFFENSIVE ZONE, HE WORKS LOW TO
HIGH.
THEY CREDITED THE MINNESOTA GOA
FOR KAPRIZOV. PICKED UPSENDS BE
REDIRECT GOES WIDE TO THE  DRIV.
MOVES IN AND FIRES OFF THE
SHOULDER OF BLACKWOOD AND OUT O
FIGHTS THROUGH THE CHECK.
TIED UP, AND IT
RI THE DEVILS
OUT THERE COME A LONG SHIFT, TH
PUCK CAME ONT KAPRIZOV AS THEY
HIT THE LINE.
WITH DEFENSEMAN DUMBA AND FIRES
JUST WIDE
PROVIDES AT RISK CHILDREN'S WIT
EXPERIENCES THAT EXPIRE DREAMS
AND ACHIEVEMENTS FOR A LIFETIME
CE
'S PIECE KAHKONEN I I THE OFFEN
TONIGHT.
A THREE-POINT NIGHTOT DEFLECTS
CLASS.LD MATCH THAT WIN
STREAK IF THEY CAN HATOUCH THE
KAPRIZOV